welcoming back to the program today John
Guan dolo who's a former Marine and FBI
agent who now runs the organization
understanding the threat strategic
operational training and consulting on
the threat of the global Islamic
movement John it's great to have you
back not only because the FBI has become
such a topic of newsworthiness over the
last few years but also just because
it's great to follow up with folks we've
interviewed we had you on back in 2013
and at the time you talk to us about how
you believe that then CIA director
nominee John Brennan had been recruited
by Saudi Arabia and converted to Islam
now that he has come and gone do you
still stand by that do you believe John
Brennan was secretly or is secretly a
Muslim well we know as a matter of fact
from my own sources who were in Saudi
Arabia when John Brennan was a station
chief that he said the Shahada in the
presence of Saudi officials including
Baba hethe Saudi intelligence officials
we now have retired station chief from
the CIA Brad Johnson who has now come
out publicly and said it was well known
and is well known in the CIA that John
Brennan converted to Islam and he had
heard that for many people who had
direct knowledge and heard things direct
from for mr. Brennan so I don't think
that that is a question anymore
although some people would try to make
it so so yes obviously stand by my
comments why don't you think that it's
been reported in any sort of
investigative news outlet or corporate
media or even really in much independent
media that that the the former CIA
director had converted to Islam but sort
of kept that secret why that seems like
it would be a story that would be for
the media outlets that make money from
getting clicks and so on wouldn't they
want to publish such such an explosive
story why wouldn't they I would think so
but I think there are many what I would
call explosive stories that aren't being
published certainly not by what I would
call I'm gonna use the term mainstream
media since I think many of your view
we'll know what I'm talking about later
the typical ABC NBC CBS MSNBC CNN Fox
News that they're not covering this
story but I would also say he was not
the only CIA station chief in Saudi
Arabia that converted Islam now let me
ask you this Jon because I want to see
if we can define some of those terms
like when you say could so you said he
recited it's the Shahada is I hope I'm
not speaking incorrectly it's the
Shahada that he recited right yeah so
like I I'm beautiful Jewish right if I
go to I don't know a Catholic Church and
get baptized a Catholic might say David
Pakman isn't is now Catholic but if I
didn't really do it in a serious manner
if I don't identify as Catholic doesn't
really matter that I was quote baptized
right like that wouldn't make me
Catholic any more than if I just right
now recited the Shahada would so are you
do you agree with that or do you believe
that something irreversible sort of
happens when you say a certain thing or
or if I were baptized right well I think
the premise of your question is not
quite right so if you first of all you
would not be allowed to be baptized in
the example you gave in a Catholic
Church unless you had gone through so as
an adult if you had gone through a
certain process that's that's set up for
you to be to begin your initiation into
the church so no you're not Catholic
because the process would would include
baptism and your your confirmation and
communion sure but then the same thing
applies I mean if I did it and didn't
really do it in a serious way that
that's what I feel in my heart I'm just
going through the motions am I really
Catholic well so we can step away from
talking about Catholicism the answer is
it's not a the answer isn't actually you
don't get to do those things unless you
understand what you're doing in full
faith in Islam the law because Islam is
a totalitarian system governed by
Sharia law yes if you publicly say the
Shahada under the circumstances that the
law requires then you have accepted
Islam and have converted and that's all
it requires and if you read what islam
teaches you are not required to
understand what the fullness of sharia
requires they only are required to tell
you enough so that you come into Islam
without and I would argue that many
people are not aware that leaving Islam
as a capital crime so they only give you
enough which is is exactly the opposite
of how for instance again staying with
your example Christianity treats it that
when you come into the full communion of
the church you know you are taught the
full body of what the faith is in Islam
they are not required to tell you they
tell you enough to get you to say the
Shahada there there by you or a Muslim
and once you're in you can't leave no
camel - so let's let's play it out now
let's say Brennan Brennan was a secret
Muslim what I observed take place under
Brennan's stewardship and under
President Obama were drone strikes and
bombing of multiple majority Muslim
countries significant military action
against Isis did Brennan as a secret
Muslim do anything as a result of being
Muslim in your estimation well they
certainly supported I mean we could
start with today and we're back but I'll
I'll bounce around to answer your
question I mean he supported the u.s.
Muslim Brotherhood both through the
actions as the counterterrorism adviser
to the President and as the CIA director
by not only appearing at Muslim
Brotherhood functions and promoting them
and advising the President to promote
them such as the Islamic Society of
North America and others he the the
policies if we look at what happened
under President Obama if you look at the
leaders around the
that we're really the only leaders that
were putting the boot on the Muslim
Brotherhood Muammar Qaddafi in in Syria
Assad Mubarak in Egypt the Obama
administration removed Mubarak had
Qadhafi killed and is trying to remove
Assad so that that should be noteworthy
I mean Muammar Qaddafi was killing more
al-qaeda fighters than anyone else on
the planet at the time so I I think that
is the problematic because the who they
were targeting were those who were
honestly enemies of the United States in
other words Qaddafi Assad Mubarak and
and I'm not defending those three
individuals but what they were doing
we're keeping the global Islamic
movement specifically the Muslim
Brotherhood at bay and we basically
ripped those down and now we see the
results of that as a seek I guess I'm
confused because as a secret Muslim
wouldn't Brennan's involvement in an
escalation of the droning of of Muslim
individuals be something that according
to his own secret religion Islam would
send him to hell like how why would he
agree to participate in that why would
he further that policy that we saw
escalated under Obama right well my
first question to somebody asking my
first answer to somebody asking that
question is what Islamic law have you
read and if you read Islamic law it's
very clear and when they're when you see
Muslims in conflict with other Muslims
it's always a it's always about one of
two issues matters of Sharia or power
and so if we're gonna look at the
geopolitical relationships between Iran
Saudi Arabia Iraq other nations like
that what happened in Libya what's
happening in Syria you have to
understand Sharia and you have to
understand the power struggles and so
Sharia does provide for these things and
again it's going to be one of those two
things it's going to be matters of
Sharia and matters of power and you
got both going on right now in the
Middle East so if I'm understanding what
you're saying too kind of like tidy it
up anything that John Brennan did as a
secret Muslim CIA director that appears
to be anti-muslim was actually in
furthering the interests of a power
struggle in a way that would be
sanctioned by Sharia law and would not
condemn him to hell if he were actually
operating according to Sharia now his
loyalties based on just if we just look
at what we can visibly see in and I want
to be clear you're using the phrase
secret Muslim secret society I'm I'm
saying he said the Shahada he didn't
seem to be secretive about it
he's never been asked by the media
directly about it which is a little
shocking since now like I said six or
seven months ago you've got a retired
very successful station chief of the CIA
and and others but is it jogging though
maybe there may be just no one cuz I
remember last time we talked you had
said I think it was your wife who speaks
Arabic who heard transmissions about it
but that I think for a lot of so-called
mainstream media might not be sufficient
evidence to say that John Brennan
converted to Islam you know well I that
was not me that said that I don't have a
wife that speaks Arabic but I will say
that when you have a station chief at
the CIA saying that it was well-known in
the agency that he had converted Islam I
think that's a very powerful statement
the fact that the media ignores out I
can't
subscribe to why they would do that yeah
it's weird
oh I'm saying is if you look at mr.
Brennan's actions he clearly supports
the Muslim Brotherhood the president of
United States who was advised by mr.
Brennan both as a TT adviser and as the
CIA director director of Central
Intelligence openly supported the Muslim
Brotherhood against a sitting leader in
in Egypt Mubarak who was keeping the
Muslim Brotherhood at bay and now after
that revolution that we supported that
overthrew Mubarak
now there was the counter-revolution and
we have a non Muslim Brotherhood
government we see the Muslim Brotherhood
locked up we see stability back in Egypt
but the point is yeah what we see is and
what we saw were mr. Brennan's actions
were Pro revolutionary and pro
supportive of the Muslim Brotherhood so
that's I mean those are just facts on
the table that I would I can't imagine
that anybody could dispute it this bomb
well John in the limited time we have
left as a former FBI guy how do you
assess Robert molars handling of the
Trump Russia investigation
well since as of today there is no
evidence that the president United
States in any way took actions with a
foreign government that affected u.s.
elections as a matter of fact it's the
opposite mrs. Clinton
Clinton's campaign definitely did as a
matter of fact they supported the FISA
application that went to a FISA Court
which had information that was
objectively untrue and omitted
information that would have brought a
significant question to that FISA
application that was submitted and by
the way Johnny I have to interrupt
though I have to drop isn't it true that
there is substantially more evidence to
support Trump Russia collusion than John
Brennan meet being a Muslim right I mean
you've got the Trump Tower meeting
you've got the indictments guilty pleas
well like what's your standard of
evidence for saying that it's obvious
that John Brennan is a secret Muslim but
there's no reason to even look into
Trump Russia collusion how do you come
to that conclusion I didn't say there
was no reason not to look into it if
there are real accusations and real
basis of fact right now there is not one
fact on the table that mr. Trump worked
with the government of Russia which is
the the accusation in order to affect US
elections there is no evidence of that
that's not true if you believe his
attorney Michael Cohen he knew about and
went forward with a meeting with Russian
agents in Trump Tower specifically to
receive
information from them meant to be
damaging to Hillary Clinton to improve
his chances of winning the election now
you might say it hasn't been proven in
court yet that's fine but that's a
specific allegation at this time that's
being investigated it's an allegation
that's unproven there is no evidence on
the table mr. Muller himself if you look
at what he's put on the table that are
facts that we can grasp onto that is not
one of them that's on the table
well molars there's running an
investigation his job is not to make
public all the evidence he has he's
running an investigation right you
weren't you were at the FBI you know
that they don't make the public aware of
every piece of evidence they have that
would be it wouldn't make any sense of
course not okay with you there but the
fact is there is we do not have evidence
that mr. Trump colluded or worked with
and specifically worked with a foreign
government any foreign government in
order to affect the elections when in
fact there is a substantial amount of
evidence that mrs. Clinton did among
among other things I mean the fact that
she and and it appears that the
president United States now with the
evidence that is as an investigator that
we can't say for sure but there is a lot
of evidence that points to the fact that
mr. clapper mr. Brennan and the
President himself knew that that FISA
application went in with information
that was knowingly false to spy on US
citizens including a candidate for the
president I'd stay which is in violation
of federal law okay unfortunately we
can't adjudicate that right now but I do
appreciate John Guan dolo former Marine
and FBI agent giving our audience an
update on where he is on the Brennan
Muslim issue and also on the Trump
Russia investigation John appreciate you
taking the time to come back and talk to
us thank you and I appreciate your time
to speak with you thank you